let's now account for the same series of
events but instead of doing it on a cash
basis let's do it on an accrual basis
and the whole idea with accrual
accounting is to match your revenues and
expenses to when you actually perform
the service so it actually captures
business activity as opposed to just
capturing when cash is uh when cash
changes hands so let's see what that
actually means so in month one you cater
an event where the cost to you was a
hundred dollars the customer pays you
200 for your services and what i'll do
i'll do the accrual accounting right
here so this is kind of the cash income
statement let's do the accrual
accounting income statement so you
actually provided the service of
catering you got 200 for your services
so i'll put 200 in for revenue and the
expenses associated with that service
that you provided in month one is a
hundred dollars
is one hundred dollars and so your
profit is one hundred dollars so at
least for one month one the cash basis
and the accrual basis of accounting look
exactly the same and once again you have
one hundred dollars in cash now let's go
to month two you cater an event where
the cost to you was two hundred dollars
you and the customer agree that they can
pay you 400 the next month so now it
gets interesting because you performed
the catering that month and the catering
that you performed that month is worth
400
so in the on the accrual basis of
accounting you would say that you earned
400 of revenue
you would say that you earned 400 of
revenue in this month even though the
customer did not pay you they did not
give you the cash and the way that you
account for that is on your balance
sheet you say that you are essentially
owed 400 so this accounts receivable
this is this is essentially stuff that
other people owes you you need to
receive this from other people but it's
an asset other people have an obligation
to you so you have an accounts
receivable of 400. when they pay you the
400 it goes from accounts receivable to
cash
and then you ca and then the cost to you
was 200
so the cost to you was two hundred
dollars
so here all of a sudden you perform the
service the revenues and expenses for
that service are in that month and now
your profit here shows two hundred
dollars so it is actually a better
reflection of what you did that month
now the reality is is that you didn't
get the cash forward and you had to
spend 200 of cash out of your pocket so
you're still just like the cash
accounting you're still going to have
negative 100
you're still going to have negative one
hundred dollars in cash now let's go to
month three
you get four hundred dollars from the
customer in the previous month now with
cash basis you would have added that to
your revenue but here we already we
already accounted for it in the accounts
receivable we already took that revenue
but because you got the 400 in cash it's
going to disappear from receivables and
then go into cash because you actually
got it you get 400 for the customer in
the previous month you also get 200 in
advance from a customer that you have to
cater for the next month so you did no
catering in month three and because you
did no catering in month three you have
zero revenue in month three and then you
also have zero expenses the way that you
account for the four hundred dollars
that you got
is that your accounts receivables goes
to zero
and that goes to cash so that the
negative one hundred dollars gets you
add four hundred dollars to it so it'll
become positive 300 and the way that you
account for this 200
in advance from a customer is you call
that deferred revenue you got the cash
there so you got the you what we went
from negative 100 added 400 to 300 then
you get another 200 in cash so that
gives us 500
in cash again but we didn't earn any
revenue that 200
that was a kind of a cash advance so we
put that right over here in deferred
revenue that's revenue that we're
deferring to a future period in the in
the future we will earn it this is now a
liability because we are obligated to
earn that revenue and then in month four
we actually earn the revenue so in month
four
we can actually put it on our income
statement at two hundred dollars
and then
we had a hundred dollars of expenses so
that we have this hundred dollars right
over here and so in month four we earned
we earned one hundred dollars and once
again we we one hundred dollars went
away from our cash balance so we still
have four hundred dollars so whether you
do the cash basis through the accrual
basis you have the same exact amount of
cash but what's more interesting is how
the profit
relates in each of the periods and i'll
talk about that a little bit more depth
in the next video